the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lecture for today probably should
be entitled it should have been
functions but its analytic geometry
instead or a picture is worth a thousand
words what we hope to do today is to
establish the fact that whereas in the
study of calculus when we deal with rate
of change we are interested in analytic
terms that more often than not we prefer
to visualize things more intuitively in
terms of a graph or other suitable
visual aid and it actually this is not
quite as alien or as profound as it may
at first glance seem consider for
example the businessman who says profits
rose profits rose now you know profits
don't rise unless the safe blows up or
something like this what profits do is
they increase or they decrease the
reason that we say profits rise is that
when the profits are increasing if we
are plotting profit in terms of time the
resulting graph shows and a rising
tendency as the profit increases the
curves Rises and in other words then we
begin to establish the feeling that we
can identify the analytic term
increasing with the geometric term
rising and this identification whereby
difficult arithmetic concepts are
visualized pictorially is something that
begins not only very early in the
history of man but very early in the
development of the mathematics
curriculum or as a case in point
consider the problem of 5/3 versus 6/3 I
remember when I was in grade school that
this particular problem always seemed
more appealing to me than this problem
that 6/3 seemed natural but 5/3 didn't
and the reason was is that in terms of
visualizing tally marks it was much
easier to see how you divide six tallies
into groups into three groups than five
tallies
two three groups however as soon as we
pick length as soon as we pick length as
our model the idea is this Eva one can
divide a line into three parts of equal
length or one can't divide the line now
if I can geometrically divide this line
into three equal parts and in plain
geometry we learn to do this then the
fact is that I can divide this line
segment into three equal parts
regardless of how long this line happens
to be oh to be sure if this line happens
to be six units long this point is named
two and if on the other hand the line
happens to be only five inches long the
resulting point is named 5/3 but notice
that in either case I can in a very
natural way define or identify either
ratio as a point on the line and this
idea of identifying numerical concepts
called
numbers with geometric concepts called
points is a very old device and a device
that was used and still is used in the
curriculum today under the name of the
number line under the name of graphs and
what we will use as a fundamental
building block as our course develops
now you know in the same way that we can
think of a single number as being a
point on the line we can think of a pair
of numbers and ordered pair of numbers
as being a point in the plane this is de
cartes geometry which we can call
coordinate geometry the idea being that
in the same way that we can locate a
number along the x axis shall we say we
could have located a number pair as a
point in the plane namely 2 comma 3
would mean the point whose x-coordinate
was 2 and whose y-coordinate was 3 by
the way the reason that we say ordered
pairs is 2 it is if you observe 2 comma
3 and 3 comma 2 happen to be different
pairs and notice again
how vividly the geometric interpretation
of this is namely in terms of locating a
point in space it's obvious that the
point name 2 comma 3 is not the same as
the point named 3 comma 2 again the
important thing is this when I think of
5/3 when I think of the ordered pair 2
comma 3 I do not have to think of a
picture I can think of these things
analytically but the picture gives me
certain insights that will help me with
my intuition and aid that I don't want
to relinquish for example going back to
the graph again thinking of the analytic
term greater than notice how much easier
it is to think of for example higher
than C one point being higher than
another or to the right of
you see geometric concepts to name
analytic statements or instead of
increasing as we mentioned before to say
rising and there will be many many more
such identifications as we go along
with our course at any rate let's
continue to see then what is the
relationship then between functions that
we talked about and graphs the idea is
something like this let's return to our
friend of the first lecture s equals 16
T squared we can think of a distance
machine being the function where the
input will be time and the output will
be what the square of the input x 16
observe that from this I do not have to
have any picture to understand what's
happening here namely I can measure an
input measure and output and observe
analytically what is happening however
as we saw last time our graph sort of
shows us at a glance what seems to be
happening that we can we can identify
rising and falling with increasing and
decreasing and things of this type we
will explore this of course in much more
detail as we continue in our course by
the way there is no reason why the input
has to be a single number for example
why couldn't the input be an ordered
pair of numbers among other things let's
take a simple geometric example consider
for example finding the volume of a
cylinder in terms of the radius of its
base and the height we know from solid
geometry that the volume is PI R squared
H we can therefore think of a volume
machine where the input is the ordered
pair R comma H and the output is the
single number PI R squared H by the way
notice here the meaning of ordered pair
you see if the pair 2 comma 3 goes into
the machine
notice that the recipe here says what
you square the first member of the pair
in other words if 2 comma 3 is the input
we
at 2 which is 4 multiplied by 3 which is
12 and 12 times pi of course is 12 pi on
the other hand if the input is 3 comma 2
the first member is 3 our recipe squares
the first member that would be 9 times 2
is 18 times pi is 18 pi but again
observe that i at no time needed a
picture to visualize what was happening
here of course if I wanted a picture I
could try to plot this also but notice
now that my graph would probably need
three dimensions to draw and why would
it need three dimensions well notice
that my input has two independent
measurements R and H and therefore I
would need two dimensions just to take
care of our and H then I would need a
third dimension to plot V and by the way
notice the next stage if I had an input
that consisted of three independent
measurements this would still make sense
but now I would be at a loss for the
picture in other words what I'm trying
to bring out next is the fact that
whereas pictures are a tremendous help
maybe a second subtitle to our lecture
should have been a picture is worth a
thousand words provided you can draw
because you see if we needed three
independent dimensions to locate the
input and in a fourth one to locate the
output how we draw the picture by the
way this happens in high school algebra
again if you want to see the analogy
look at for example the algebraic
equation a plus B squared we learned in
algebra that this is a squared plus 2 a
B plus B squared observe that we do not
need to have a picture to understand how
this works oh to be sure if we had a
picture we get a tremendous amount of
insight as to what's happening here
namely let's visualize a square whose
side is a plus B on the one hand you see
the area of the square would be a plus B
squared you see the side squared on the
other hand if we now subdivide this
figure this way we see that that same
square is made up of four pieces
having one piece of area a squared two
pieces of area a B and one piece of area
B squared and so we see on the other
hand that the area of the square is a
squared plus 2 a B plus B squared and so
again observe that whereas this stands
on its own two legs the picture helps us
quite a bit by the way we could continue
this with a cube over here namely it
turns out that a plus B cubed is a cubed
plus 3a squared B plus 3a B squared plus
B cubed and again if we wanted to and we
won't take the time here but if we
wanted to we could now draw a cube whose
side is a plus B then we can take the
same diagram that we had before and now
make a third dimension to it and if you
did that you would see what that the
cube whose volume is a plus B cubed is
divided into eight pieces one of size a
by a by a three of size a by a by B
three of size a by B by B and one of
size B by B by B again the picture is a
tremendous visual aid now the key step
is this if we were to now give in to our
geometric intuition and say look at why
worry about algebra when it's so much
easier to do this thing by geometry the
counter example is consider a plus B to
the fourth power now by the binomial
theorem and I might add the same
binomial theorem that allowed us to get
these results we can also write that
this is what it's a to the fourth plus
four a cubed B plus six a squared B
squared plus 4a b cubed plus B to the
fourth now it's not important how we get
this result the important point is that
analytically we can raise the number to
the fourth power just as easily as we
can to the third power or the second
power the only difference is that in the
case of the second the third power
we had a picture that we could use in
the fourth power case we didn't have a
picture and what a tragedy it would have
been to
hey we can solve this problem because we
can't draw the picture and by the way as
a rather interesting aside notice the
geometric influence on how we read this
this is called a plus B to the fourth
power but somehow or other we don't call
this one a plus B to the third power we
call it a plus B cubed suggesting the
geometric configuration of the cube and
here we don't usually say a plus B to
the second power we say a plus B squared
you see the idea is that when the
picture is available it gives us a
tremendous insight as to what can be
done and it helps us learn to visualize
what's happening analytically in fact
what usually happens is we use the
picture to justify what's happening
analytically when we can see the picture
and then just carry the analytic part
through unimpeded in the case where we
can't draw the picture let me give you
another example of this let's look at
the following set that also should
review our language of sets for us let s
be the set of all ordered pairs x comma
y such that x squared plus y squared
equals 25 question the street does the
ordered pair 3 comma 4 belong to s
answer yes how do we know well we have a
test for membership we're supposed to do
what Square each of the entries each of
the numbers add them and if the answer
is 25 then that ordered pair belongs to
s 3 squared plus 4 squared is 25 so this
pair belongs to s how about 1 comma 2
well 1 squared plus 2 squared is 1 plus
4 which is 5 5 is not equal to 25 so 1
comma 2 does not belong to s well did we
need any geometry to be able to
visualize this result hopefully one did
not need any geometry to visualize this
result on the other hand then what does
it mean in analytic geometry when we say
that x squared plus y squared equals 25
is a circle as badly as I draw x squared
plus y squared equals 25 looks less like
a circle the
the circle I drew over here you see what
we really mean is this consider all the
points in the plane X comma Y for which
x squared plus y squared equals 25 these
are precisely the points on this
particular circle and the easiest way to
see that of course is that since the
radius of the circle is 5 and the point
X comma Y means that this length is X
and this length is y notice that from
the Pythagorean theorem we see at once
that x squared plus y squared equals 25
now again the solution set to this
equation is our set s whether we're
thinking of this thing algebraically or
geometrically on the other hand watch
what our picture seems to give us that
we didn't have before let's return to
our point 1 comma 2 which we saw didn't
belong to s well look at this where
would 1 comma 2 be 1 comma 2 would be
inside the circle why is that because
you see if we take the point 1 comma 2
if we take say for example the point 1
comma 2 notice that the distance from
the origin to the point 1 comma 2 is
less than 5 in other words the distance
is less than 5 so the square of the
distance is less than 25 in other words
not only can we say that 1 comma 2 does
not belong to s which we could have said
without the picture we can now say what
1 comma 2 is and notice the geometric
language here is inside the circle
in other words the study of inequalities
can now be reduced instead of talking
about less-than and greater-than we can
now talk about such things as inside and
outside you see inside the circle which
is a simple geometric concept just means
what the set of all points for which x
squared plus y squared is less than 25
outside that circle x squared plus y
squared is greater than 25 on the circle
x squared plus y squared equals 25 again
a nice identification between numbers
and pictures analysis and geometry
well this then shows us why we want to
study pictures rather than functions now
if we look at any textbook in which we
deal with graphs it always seems that we
start with graphs of straight lines and
the question is what is so great about a
straight line after all our pictures in
general are going to be much more
complicated than that what advantage is
there in starting with straight lines
and again we begin to realize how
straight lines are the backbone of all
types of analytical procedures and all
types of curve plotting for example
let's suppose we were studying this
particular curve and we wanted to know
what was happening to that curve in a
neighborhood around the point P let's
draw in the tangent line to the curve at
the point P notice that this line that
we've drawn serves as a wonderful
approximation curve itself if we stay
close enough to the point of tangency in
other words notice how much we can
deduce about this curve if we study only
the straight line segments at the point
of tangency of course the approximation
gets worse and worse as we move further
and further out but in a neighborhood of
the point of what's going on notice
again then that the straight line is an
important building block by the way
again we use straight lines in a rather
subtle way in something called
interpolation for example let's suppose
I go to a log table and I look up the
log of 2 I find that the log of 2 is
0.301 I look up the log of 4
I find that point
6:02 now I look for the log of three and
I see it's been obliterated I don't know
what it is so I say well let me guess
three is halfway between two and four
therefore I would suspect that the log
of 3 is halfway between the log of 2 and
the log of 4 and so halfway between here
would be about what 4 5 2 roughly
speaking all of a sudden the
obliteration on my book clears up and I
look and I don't find point 4 5 2
instead I find now let's write it over
here what I find is zero point four
seven seven
now you know this is a pretty big error
to attribute the slide rule inaccuracy
or trouble in rounding off the tables
what really went wrong over here and the
answer comes up again that unless
otherwise specified the process known as
interpolation hinges on replacing a
curve by a straight line approximation
in fact you see if we were to draw the
curve of the logarithm function we would
find that the picture is something like
this and when we looked up the log of
two this is what we've this height is
what we found in the table when we
looked up the log of four this height is
what we would have found in the table if
we had looked up in the table the log of
three this is the height that we would
have found this is the height that's
point four seven seven notice that in
general if we go half way from here to
here we do not go half way from here to
here it depends on the shape of the
curve the only time you can be sure that
you have proportional parts is if the
curve that joined these two points was a
straight line okay and notice by the way
that by the shape of this curve the
straight line falls below the curve and
therefore the height that we found was
to the straight line not to the curve
that was the point 4 5 2 C in other
words notice that we got a smaller than
the right answer because we approximate
it as if it was a straight line that was
joining the curve you see what
interpolation hinges on is that the size
of the interval is very small and that
you can assume that for the accuracy
that you're interested in that the
straight line approximation to the curve
is sufficiently accurate to represent
the curve itself well enough about that
once we've talked about why straight
lines are important the next thing is
how do we measure straight lines see
another interesting point is something
like this many times we know what
something means subjectively but we
don't know what it means objectively for
example one way of finding a line is to
know two points on the line another way
is to know one point and the slant of
the line the question that comes up is
how do you measure this length of a line
in other words shall you say that the
line is very slanting and if the answer
to that is yes how do you distinguish
between slanty and very slant a steep
and very steep very steep and very very
steep we need something more objective
and the way we get around this is as
follows given a line we define the slope
as follows we pick any two points on the
line and from those two points we can
measure what we call the run of the line
in other words how far you've gone this
way and the rise of the line how much
it's risen this way and what we do is we
define the slope to be the rise divided
by the run or without the Delta notation
in here y2 minus y1 over x2 minus x1 by
the way there is little problems that
come up after all our answer should not
depend on the picture it should be sort
of self-contained analytically the
question that comes up is what if I
label this point x2 y2 and this point x1
y1 what would have happened then and
observe that as long as we keep the
pairs straight it makes no difference
whether you write this or whether you
write this because you see in each case
all you've done is change the sign and
negative over negative is positive so
certainly
our answer to what a slope is is
objective enough so that's not depend on
how the points are labeled a second
objection that most people have is they
say something like well who used to say
that we picked these two points what if
I came along and picked these two points
and I now computed the slope by taking
this as by Delta Y and this as my Delta
X obviously it would be a tragedy if the
answer to the problem depended on which
pair of points you picked since the line
should have but one slope again notice
that our high school training in
geometry similar triangles motivates why
we pick ratios namely while this Delta Y
and this Delta Y may be different and
this Delta X and this Delta X may be
different what is true is that the ratio
of this Delta Y to this Delta X is the
same as the ratio of this Delta Y to
this Delta X and that's why we pick the
ratio by the way another way of talking
about ratio is if you look at Delta Y
divided by Delta X and you've had some
trigonometry it reminds you of a
trigonometric relationship namely you
look at Delta Y you look at Delta X and
you say my isn't that just the tangent
of this particular angle couldn't I
define the slope and by the way the
general symbol for slope for better or
for worse just happens to be the letter
M why couldn't I define M to be the
tangent of fee and by the way fee is the
angle that the straight line makes with
the positive x-axis and of course there
is a little subtlety here that we should
pay attention to this would be an
ambiguous definition if the scale on the
x and the y axis were not the same in
other words notice that by changing the
scale here I can distort the same
analytic information so if I agree
however that the unit on the x axis is
the same as the unit on the y axis then
I can say okay the slope is also tangent
of the angle fee I much prefer to say
it's Delta Y divided by Delta X because
then if I forget the scale I'm still in
no trouble on the other hand if we use
the tangent definition we can utilize
all we know about trigonometry to get
some other interesting results namely
the question that might come up is can
we study the slow
of two different lines very conveniently
in terms of our definition of slope and
the answer is this if we imagine now
that our lines are drawn to scale here
and here are two different lines which
I'll call l1 and l2 and we'll call the
angle that l1 makes with the positive
x-axis v1 the angular l2 makes with the
positive x-axis v2 therefore what m1 is
10v 1 m 2 is 10 feet through notice that
our formula for the tangent of the
difference of two angles you see notice
that this angle here is what since this
angle is the sum of these two this angle
here is v2 minus v1 or the negative of V
1 minus V 2 should have had this feet 2
minus V 1 but since that just changes a
sign that will not have any bearing on
the point I want to make let's continue
this way tangent to fiy 1 minus V 2 is
10 feet 1 minus 10 V 2 over 1 plus 10 V
110 V 2 on the other hand by our
definitions of m1 and m2 this is m1
minus m2 over 1 plus m1 m2 excuse me now
this tells me how to find the angle
between two lines just in terms of
knowing the slope two very special
interesting cases as extremes suggest
themselves right away one case is what
happens if the lines are parallel if the
lines are parallel you see V 1 equals V
2 in which case V 1 minus V 2 is 0 in
which case the tangent of V 1 minus V 2
had better be 0 but the only way a
fraction can be 0 is for the numerator
to be 0 and that means that M 1 must
equal M 2 in other words in terms of
slopes we can study parallel lines just
by equating their slopes a less obvious
relationship that's equally important is
how do you measure whether two lines are
perpendicular the answer is if they're
perpendicular the angle between them is
90 degrees the tangent of 90 degrees is
infinity as we learned that's equivalent
to saying what that the denominator is
zero
see the only way a fraction blows up is
for the denominator to be zero but the
only way that one plus m1 m2 can be zero
is for what m1 m2 to be equal to minus
one and this gives us the other very
well-known result that in terms of
slopes to study whether two lines are
perpendicular all we need to investigate
is whether one slope is the negative
reciprocal of the other well again the
textbook will bring out slopes in more
detail the next question that we'd like
to bring up is in terms of a picture is
worth a thousand words is how do you
identify the equation the straight line
with an algebraic equation what do we
mean by the equation of a straight line
well again there are two possibilities
the first possibility is that the line
is parallel to the y-axis
if the line is parallel to the y-axis if
the line goes through the point a comma
zero notice that the only criteria for
the point to be on that line is that its
x-coordinate equal a by the way this is
often abbreviated in a textbook as the
line x equals a many a student says how
do you know this is aligned why is this
the point x equals a and here again is a
good review of why we stress the
language of sets here again is a good
reason why we change we express the
language of sets so strongly namely go
back to the universe of discourse here
when you see the set of all ordered
pairs x comma y for which x equals a
this gives you the hint that you're
talking about pairs of points and that
tells you that you have numbers in the
plane not on the line a - not on the x
axis a two-dimensional interpretation
over here you see if this said the set
of all x such that x equals a it would
just be a point but notice the hint over
here at any rate this then becomes the
equation of a straight line if the
straight line is parallel to the y-axis
of course the other possibility is what
if the line isn't parallel to the x axis
and hit through we say ok suppose we
know a point on the line and suppose we
know the slope of the line what we will
do is is pick any other point
in the plane which we will label
arbitrarily X comma Y and see what
equation X comma Y has to satisfy how do
the coordinates have to be related to be
on this line
well we already know that slope does not
depend on which two points you pick
consequently since the slope of this
line is M the slope must also be what Y
minus y1 over x2 minus x1 and this
becomes the fundamental definition for
the equation of a line which is not
parallel to the y-axis and by the way
again I think M s and X ones and Y ones
tend to give you a bit of hardship at
first till you get used to them let's
illustrate this thing with a specific
example suppose I say to you I am
thinking of the line whose slope is 3
and which passes through the point 2
comma 5 and notice the language of sets
here to say that 2 comma 5 is on the
line is the same as saying that 2 comma
5 belongs to the set of points
determined by the line drawing a rough
sketch over here and by the way notice
something very important here I never
have to draw to scale because you see
all I'm going to use is the analytic
terms and 2 comma 5 is still 2 & 5 no
matter how I draw the picture so for
example if I say ok let's see what it
means for the point X comma Y to belong
here I say well what does that mean my
slope is going to have to be what Y
minus 5 that's my rise my run is X minus
2 and that must equal 3 and if I clear
this a fractions I get what Y is equal
to 3 X minus 1
by the way this checkout if X is 2 2
times 3 is 6 minus 1 is 5 2 comma 5 is
on the line you see here's the thing we
talked about the line geometrically now
I have an algebraic equation I no longer
have to refer to the picture I have
something analytic now for example
suppose a person says to me I wonder if
the point 8 comma 23 is on this line I
don't have to draw a picture to scale I
don't have to waste any time I know that
the equation of my line is y equals 3x
minus 1 by the way if y equals 3x minus
1 as soon as X is 8
as soon as X is 8 what must y equal y
must equal what 23 is that right and so
is the point is the point 8 comma 23 on
the line yes how about 8 comma 12 8
comma 12 isn't on the line because 3
times 8 minus 1 is not 12 but notice
that we can even see algebraically that
8 comma 12 must be below the line in
other words our study of equations
allows us not only to visualize lines as
equations but we can also visualize
inequalities as pictures in other words
if we have the equation of a line if we
have the equation of a line if this is
the line y equals say 3x plus 1 or
something like this then what is this
region here these are all those values
which lie whose heights lie below the
height to be on the curve again not a
very clear example in the sense of
drawing the picture neatly for you but
our main aim is not to draw any pictures
here our main aim is to show how
analytic terms can be studied very
conveniently in terms of pictures in
fact perhaps to conclude today's lesson
what we should talk about is an old
algebraic concept called simultaneous
equations suppose you're asked to solve
these equations
say well let's see if y equals 3x minus
1 and it's also equal to X plus 1 that
says that X plus 1 equals 3x minus 1
I now solve this thing algebraically I
get 2x equals 2 so x equals 1 knowing
that x equals 1 I can see that y equals
2 and I see that 1 comma 2 is my
solution in other words if I want look
at this thing algebraically 1 comma 2 is
the only member that belongs to both of
these 2 solution sets now again notice
how I can solve this purely analytic
problem without recourse to a picture on
the other hand if I want to think of
this thing pictorially notice that y
equals 3x minus 1 is the equation of a
particular straight line and y equals x
plus 1 is also the equation of a line
notice that since these two lines are
not parallel they intersect at one
particular point and the geometric
problem that I solved on the previous
board turns out to be that the point 1
comma 2 is the point that both of these
lines have in common in fact if we call
this line as before l1 and if we name
this l2 in the language of sets 1 comma
2 is what the point which is the
intersection of the two lines l1 and l2
again a geometric interpretation for an
analytic problem in fact notice also how
much mileage I can get out of the
geometric picture for example notice
that this region here has a very nice
geometric interpretation it's a set of
what all points which are below this
line and above this line in other words
what to be below this line y must be
less than X plus 1 and to be above this
line y must be greater than 3x minus 1
notice then that a pair of simultaneous
inequalities
which may not be that easy to handle are
very easy to handle in terms of regions
in the plane notice also that since two
lines can either be parallel or not
parallel we also get a nice geometric
interpretation as to why simultaneous
equations may have one solution namely
the lines are not parallel and hence
they intersect or no solutions the lines
could have been parallel without
intersecting or infinitely many
solutions the two lines could have been
different equations in effect I should
say what the two equations could have
been different equations for the same
line again this may seem a little bit
sketchy and rapid but all we want to do
is give the overview the reading
assignment and the text goes into great
detail on the points that we've
mentioned so far but again in summary
what our lesson was supposed to be today
was to indicate the importance of being
able to visualize and to identify
analytic results with geometric pictures
and so until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate